we are counting down to the tony awards
sunday right here on cbs and this
morning we're joined by two broadway
stars darren chris and julianne huff
they are hosting an hour of the award
show that will air exclusively on our
streaming service paramount plus of
course it's called the tony awards act
one and there will be special
performances and awards darren and
julianne are also starring in broadway
shows of their own darren is returning
to broadway for the third time to play
bobby in the classic drama american
buffalo and a couple blocks away
julianne plays dusty in the comedy potus
or behind every great dumbass
and every great dumbass are seven women
trying to keep them alive it is her
broadway debut and they are here good
morning good morning morning
thank you for having us have you seven
badass women i should say i know
definitely
that's totally acceptable to say on
television i know because
[Laughter]
a lot of what the play is about i don't
think i could actually say probably
could not yeah a lot of the
perspective plays i don't think would be
appropriate for this morning so you'll
have to buy a ticket and hear that for
yourselves in person come and see both
of these stars on broadway so let me ask
you about this special on primark plus
like how exciting is it for you guys to
be together and doing this well first of
all the tony awards are personally one
of my favorite uh nights of the year um
mainly because uh something something
that jules has been able to experience
which is the the vibrancy of the theater
community um which is already without
the pageantry of award shows is such a
special and very unique thing that is so
uh such a part of the genetic cultural
material of new york city um so just
having a night to honor so many people
that that keep broadway alive is so much
fun but um jules and i worked together
on a couple of fun things before and
i've always admired her from from both
near and far and to see us both you know
singing and dance on our way across
raider city stage is something pretty
pretty cool pretty iconic and i think in
general like this is my first experience
coming out to new york and being a part
of the broadway community and that's
exactly what it is the the community is
so generous and kind and welcoming but
i'll say also after the last couple
years like broadway coming back in the
75th anniversary i mean this is truly an
honor to be able to be asked to to host
this first act at the tony awards so
it's pretty cool we have a lot of
excitement in the house and we're also
returning radio city music yes that's
right
and set the stage and speaking of which
you you wrote the music and the lyrics
for your opening number yeah
what was that process like uh well i
mean i've i've i started my my way in
the entertainment uh
bowling alley as where i don't know if
it's called that uh
but you just coined it yeah sure i don't
know i i sort of cut my teeth as a
songwriter and as a composer and so i've
as a theater nerd i've always wanted to
write a song for the tonys and so when
they asked me to post this i was like
all right there's a quid pro quo here uh
i if i'll do it if you let me write the
opening number and so jules and i are
doing the song called set the stage and
that'll be opening the whole the whole
shebang very cool
theater people are the most fun people
you mentioned the community if i could
do high school again forget sports i
would be a theater nerd for for no you
wouldn't i was somebody who's a theater
and who got like i won't say beat up but
who got harassed a lot by these by the
jocks
i don't know bro you wouldn't want to
trade places with me i would definitely
the parties were much better in
retrospect also the long-term effects
we'll just put it that way
segment we can yeah
you are who you hang out with uh i want
to ask about your pre-show rituals i'm
fascinated by them you put on a great
song jules just dance away how did that
start yeah you know i mean
like anything i love to have a ritual
before i go on stage just so it like
puts me in that zone connects me to that
performance for every night and i love
connection and so to be able to share
this the moment with all of our
incredible cast members and you know
it's all about you know figuring out
what they want so i'll send a note to
them being like what's the song for
today and um yeah it's just fun it just
kind of became our thing and um they
they always know at 7 30 i'm gonna be
blasting music throughout the the
theater so
just coming in hot with something it's a
lot cleaner than ours
how you seeing it you're just looking at
it now you're like wait a second i gotta
i gotta
yeah what do you do before a show uh i
mean it does it definitely doesn't look
as cool as that although sam rockwell is
a terrific dancer and he will he'll
definitely cut a rug we'll blast some
funk music but backstage you know uh
lawrence fishburne is a very
nimble athletic man so i i try and copy
him when he does all this kind of tai
chi kind of stuff every now and then
he'll he'll shoot me a morpheus he'll do
one of those oh my gosh and i squeal
inside it's very strange well you know
vanessa williams is a part of our show
too and like
again legend iconic but she started
dancing and ballroom dancing and that
was the first person that i ever saw in
ballroom dancing in a movie and so like
we we actually you know backstage we're
dancing leah delaria julie white rachel
dratch i mean it's like the craziest
cast and so just getting together and
you know cutting a rug it's the best
yeah no vanessa and dance with me i
thought yeah that was the movie yeah it
was a great movie but
your broadway debut is potus quickly why
did you choose it you know i think it's
always been a dream of mine to
be on broadway and i didn't want to just
do it as like a bucket list like i mean
i'm out i really wanted to immerse
myself into the the world and the
community and you know susan strowman
the director is like a legend i love her
i look up to her so much uh selena
fillinger the playwright um she wrote
this when she was 24 and it's an
all-female cast and i think just where
we're at in the world today like having
so much female empowerment surrounding
something like politics that could feel
very heavy and we do it in such a
hilarious you know outlandish
way i think is what we need right now of
badass ladies really funny i know i can
say that you say that keep saying
but it's really funny and i think like
that's what we need right now i hear you
i hear that yeah well you two look great
together
[Laughter]
thank you appreciate it uh you can watch
aaron and julian co-host the tony awards
act one this sunday at 7 pm eastern 4
p.m pacific exclusively on paramount
plus it will be immediately followed by
the 75th annual tony awards 8 eastern 5
pacific right here on cbs and streaming
on paramount plus live